[Musique]
celle qui assise sur le canapé
les enfants y en a qu'une oui deux
affiches différentes pour un même film
au public français on présente une
histoire de famille alors qu'aux états
unis le message est plus politique
ce film qu'apparemment l'iran ne veut
pas que le monde voit ses persepolis de
marjane satrapi et vincent paronnaud et
dans cette classe de 4e du collège de
bagdad
on s'apprête à aller le voir au cinéma
une séance organisée spécialement pour
les collégiens dans le cadre collège au
cinéma collège au cinéma c'est un
dispositif qui est dans l'académie 40
collège du haut rhin y participent et le
but en fait c'est de faire découvrir un
certain nombre d'élèves un cinéma qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude de voir et donc il
s'agit d'aller voir trois films durant
l'année un film de patrimoine du
patrimoine français un film étranger est
un film un petit peu différent la fête
est biblique
premièrement opérationnel depuis 2003
dans le haut-rhin et 2008 dont le bas
rhin le dispositif en temps et éveiller
la curiosité des jeunes spectateurs et
leur donner les premières bases une
éducation à l'image
voilà des années que madame magie emmène
ses classes au ciné à patates collège au
cinéma c'est une opération bien huilée
nous avons commencé par une séance
d'introduction avant d'aller voir le
film où on voit la bande annonce du film
ont réfléchi sur la fiche on compare
aussi la fiche française du film à
d'autres affiches comme la fiche
américaine et ont fait réfléchir les
élèves déjà sur la fiche le graphisme de
la fiche savez puis deuxième temps on va
au cinéma voir le film et puis en
troisième temps on revient sur ce qu'on
a vu avec les impressions des élèves le
but étant effectivement qu'ils aient des
réponses argumentées ils ont droit
d'aimer ou de ne pas aimer le film mais
surtout d'avoir des arguments ça c'est
un petit peu plus difficile
donc c'est l'argumentation et travailler
énormément en troisième pour le brevet
las à partir d'un film donc c'est aussi
une aide pédagogique pour nous
les avant d'emmener les élèves à la
découverte du septième art les
professeurs doivent se former
c'est l'objectif de cet atelier organisé
par alsace cinéma une soixantaine
d'enseignants ils sont présents pour
discuter du film du second semestre
ils ont vu ou revu fenêtre sur cour
d'alfred hitchcock
1 et cet après midi donc j'en ai
fischbach qui le formateur va leur
donner un certain nombre de pistes
pédagogiques avec lesquels ils vont
pouvoir travailler avec les élèves
collège au cinéma chaque année c'est
plusieurs centaines de séances 30000
places pour accueillir 11 mille
collégiens dans toute l'alsace le
département du haut-rhin finance
l'opération afin que le plus grand
nombre d'élèves puissent y participer
côté organisation c'est le réseau des
cinémas indépendants d'alsace qui est à
la manoeuvre
baldassi masse et la coordination du
dispositif sur l'ensemble des deux
départements du haut-rhin du bas-rhin 1
et c'est le c'est l'organisation des
séances
ça représente plusieurs centaines de
séances sur sur les deux départements et
donc c est celle là on fait le lien
entre les établissements scolaires les
salles de cinéma
[Musique]
dispositif national une liste de films
est proposé chaque année par le
ministère de la culture
à charge pour chaque académie de décider
quels films seront projetés aux élèves
petite spécificité alsacienne ici ce
sont les enseignants qui décide des
films du programme pour le niveau 4e 3e
qui donc le niveau 2
de la formation d'aujourd'hui les films
du 1er trimestre aidé persepolis de
marjane satrapi le film étudié
aujourd'hui c'est fenêtre sur cour
d'alfred hitchcock ses films de
patrimoine
il fume étrangers seraient vidés au
troisième trimestre mc blanca niévès de
pablo berger
[Musique]
on retrouve nos collégiens devant le
palace à mulhouse en toile de fond de
l'opération familiariser les jeunes avec
très obscures bah c'est important parce
que enfin depuis ça fait quelques années
que les spectateurs depuis 50 ans sont
plus nombreux que ceux de moins de 25 et
je pense que ces dispositifs permettent
de aux collégiens de trouver le chemin
de la salle de cinéma révolution et
qu'après le décès dans l'autriche après
ne se sont pas dans nos colonnes en iran
après avoir en france
retour au collège après la projection
une séance est consacrée aux des briques
du film c'était bien moi j'ai bien aimé
l'histoire
par contre moi j'aime pas trop cassant
en noir et blanc mais ça l'est je trouve
que ça nous apporte d'autres choses ça
nous montre la vie que d'autres
personnes pas avoir qui n'ont pas la
même que nous à des moments j'ai bien
aimé parce que ça rappelait les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
quant à elle se rebellaient contre les
gens moi de mon âme je serais pas allé
voir ce film mais ça fait découvrir
d'autres choses autrement
[Musique]
objectif de la discussion en classe
permettre aux élèves d'exprimer leur
ressenti et surtout les initier à
exprimer une crédit construite avec
laquelle elles ne sont pas toujours
familiers ils sont dans le j'aime j'aime
pas je me suis ennuyée ça m'a plu donc
c'est vrai que essayer de leur montrer
que même si on n'a pas aimé on a pu
comprendre l'oeuvre essayer de leur
montrer que finalement c'est peut-être
ennuyeux persepolis parce que c'est noir
et blanc mais que ce noir et blanc a un
sens enfin essayer de leur montrer le
sens des choses pas pour qu'ils aiment à
la fin parce que l'émotion est là mais
pour comment ils comprennent que c'est
une oeuvre d'art avec des choix avec des
buts et avec avec quelque chose qui va
au delà de la première impression qu on
a
mais voilà les personnes voilà des
marionnettes de qui on le voit avec ce
personnage dans des anglais les anglais
qui propose au delà de l'expression
orale qui est maintenant évaluée au
brevet les films visionnés serviront de
support pour différents cours dans
différentes matières alors ça dépend des
films cette année là persepolis on va
l'exploiter essentiellement en français
en lettres et en histoire géo puisque le
film s'y prête pour le deuxième film
fenêtre sur cour s'est en revanche ma
collègue d'anglais qui va être sollicité
puisque le film est sous-titré ça aussi
c'est une grande première pour les
élèves de voir des films sous titrés et
blanche neige qui est un film un petit
peu plus particulier pourra être
exploité éventuellement aussi de façon
plastique dans le collègue d'arts
plastiques pour ces collégiens hyper
connectés et abreuvé d'image le cinéma
est un bon moyen de capter leur
attention
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ces films
sont tout simplement une autre façon
d'aborder des points du programme
je verrai utiliser ce film certains
passages du film dans plusieurs de mes
séquences sur ma séquence sur la poésie
par exemple dire la mort en poésie je
vais revoir la séquence au cours de
laquelle marc jet amoureuse de marcus
pour montrer aux élèves que la poésie
c'est pas seulement un texte la poésie
peut se trouver ailleurs notamment dans
des images dans une usine dans une façon
de tourner les oueds tourner les images
de mettre en scène je vais aussi ré
exploiter ça pour un rappel sur la
biographie puisqu'on a vu ça en trois
ans 5e et qu'on reverra la biographie en
troisième l'autobiographie donc ça
permet finalement ce n'est pas un
travail qui va se faire au cours d'une
séance sur le film c'est vraiment un
film que je vais pouvoir exploiter tout
le tout au long de l'année dans
plusieurs séquences et revenir dessus
chaque fois en étudiant certains
extraits qui seront appropriés aussi con
ce que je ferai
former le regard des jeunes aux oeuvres
cinématographiques c'est l'objectif du
dispositif collège au cinéma
afin de valoriser leur apprentissage un
concours de critique est organisée dans
toute l'alsace
les plus cinéphiles des élèves ont
jusqu'au 4 mai pour participer